There's something very special about VR.
It gives you a sense of presence,
it gives you a sense of immersion that you can't really find anywhere else.
And that gives you
that emotional connection that I think is very special about that medium.
Working in VR is a new pencil,
it is a new way of getting your creativity and your ideas across.
Unreal Engine is absolutely game into technology.
But the world I think of tomorrow,
the world even of today I think is evolving very quickly
because many industries have gravitated towards Unreal Engine.
The way that these courses are structured is that
they will take you through the very first portions
of jumping in and learning how to approach Unreal Engine as a toolset,
they will take you through a series of projects,
you will build those projects and those will give
you ideas about how you approach your own work.
I strongly encourage everyone to learn everything they can jump and take this course,
the demand is out there.